i just haven't met you yet
how it started
versus how it's going let's go back
yep michael buble and his wife lusada
are expecting baby number four dropping
their big baby surprise in a new video
i'll never not love you
buble and his wife pay tribute to
hollywood's timeless love stories but
save the very best for last of course
i'm not kidding i made a music video the
likes you've never seen and michael
confirmed the exciting news to on air
with ryan seacrest this will be the
first time that i actually
say these words but yes my wife and i
are grateful to be expected oh my god hi
michael hello now when we talked to him
just last week he did try to tease that
this video was mostly about chicken it
is me
and my wife
going through our favorite scenes in
cinematic history
while eating
chicken stop it but i was on to him wait
a second i did see a video where you
guys were doing the notebook thing right
i'm just saying easter eggs there's
easter eggs through this it's gonna be
it's so good
but of course their baby announcement
pays tribute to michael's 2009 hit
haven't met you yet and only we were on
set while michael gushed about his then
girlfriend luke your girlfriend's in the
music video
how fun is that it was so much fun
what's weird is that um
i mean the song was inspired by her so
and it was and she's a great actor the
happy couple has been married since 2011
and have three beautiful kids congrats
to their growing family